I understand occur and Wolfram research
and I'm going to be presenting
automotive data analysis where I've
tracked some information in my car for a
couple years now and have some neat
information to show
I guess I'll go and get started then my
name is Andrew Stein Hawker normally I
work on the food and nutrition content
and the Wolfram language but today I'm
going to be talking about a data science
project that I've been kind of been
working on for a couple years now I'm
sort of on and off as a side project so
things are not as polished as you might
hope them to be that's because I didn't
have a lot of time to really do it when
I first started working on it but
anyways moving forward where I'm going
to be talking about some automotive data
analysis this giant paragraph of text
here basically kind of explains it but
it's probably easier to just look at the
outline it's probably a lot more simple
basically I started by collecting gas
mileage information in my car in kind of
a low-tech way using web forms in the
Wolfram cloud and that wasn't really
enough for me I was really interested in
going further so I looked at looked into
analyzing traffic on my cars CANbus more
details on that later and then
eventually I made a user interface to be
able to help me analyze that stuff
better and I created an entity store to
do that stuff and then I sort of aligned
to some GPS information that I have from
my phone and that sort of stuff so
really quick and dirty that's kind of
helping us go so a couple years ago like
I mentioned I created a web form that
allowed me to when I would get gas in my
car basically punch in the numbers that
are on the the receipt and keep track of
how much gas I used how much it cost and
that sort of thing and then attach it to
an automated report system in the cloud
so there's a link there and a QR code if
you're interested and it's been
interesting there's some neat stuff to
notice like it gets really when it's
cold outside if I can find my cursor
here gas mileage is significantly worse
I left the car warm up a lot longer
because you know it's better on the
components and stuff some neat stuff
with the prices like a huge drop right
at beginning of the year so there's a
couple of neat things some that I found
in that but I really wasn't satisfied
with that level of detail because
sometimes it could be like two weeks or
something like that before we get gas
and I really wanted to get more
information
there and there was a display in my car
that shows the instantaneous gas mileage
and the average and that sort of stuff
and I really wondered how can I tap into
that and actually you know go further so
I did just that after lots of rabbit
hole searching and stuff like that
learning I learned how to sniff the
traffic on the can bus which is humma
the little port that you can use to you
know troubleshoot problems in your car
and so basically in a nutshell um I've
learned quite a bit about it but kind of
to boil it down more or less it's it's a
bus standard that basically has two
wires that are attached to every
controller in the car and so as you can
imagine a modern car has lots and lots
of parts that all need to be connected
some parts need to be connected to
others some to many it's kind of hard to
run all those wires so they came up with
the system that's about as old as
Mathematica that is just two wires and a
communication protocol so that you don't
need to have a host or anything like
that to communicate things so it's a
fairly simple thing at least
conceptually speaking and so more or
less this is what the structure kind of
looks like more or less there's like
eight bytes of eight bytes of data or up
to eight bytes of data and then about
almost four bytes of of an ID that
describes who's sending it what it's for
and that sort of stuff and then there's
some you know nice things with it - like
the priorities like for the steering
wheel are going to be much more
important than the fan speed that you
have you know in the cabin or something
like that for the comfort of the driver
so the lower IDs are prioritized more
and that sort of thing it's also nice
and stable so that if you send something
and nobody gets it you can just keep
sending it and so then other devices
will accurate knowledge when they've
actually gotten the information from
there so it's a fairly simple thing
basically in a nutshell you really need
to get from this is there's basically 12
bytes of important information for for
the ID and up to eight for the actual
data itself so how did I do this well if
you if you want to do this too you're
probably going to need to have some
parts most importantly probably a
microcontroller of some kind I myself
just use an Arduino Uno you're going to
need some way to interface with the can
itself I've seen people make circuits
themselves I'm not that good so I just
used a shield
and I also have another shield to be
able to keep track of the time and store
things in the SD card so this is sort of
the completed sandwich if you want to
think of it that way so it's sort of
plug and play since I'm not as strong on
hardware as I am on software some other
notes with this - you're going to need
some cables obviously connection from
the obd2 port to the db9 that's on the
thing on the actual can shield itself
you'll need some power to it and for
speed reasons I've attached a square
wave a wire from the square wave on the
RTC into an interrupt so I can just
count the number of seconds since it
started up it's it's much smaller and
faster that way as we'll see in a minute
and for safety reasons I've done some
other things like removing some
resistors that are optional since they
already exist and I've put on silent
mode in the library I use because I
don't really want to send any data in a
moving car I don't really trust that so
much so I've done everything that I can
to make it as passive as possible so
that I just listened and so I get a lot
of information back and so I kind of
fought with the format at first of how I
wanted to store it and my original idea
just to get things together was to do
you know the hour minute second and then
you know the ID and then you know all
the information from the data there but
it turns out is really large and really
slow to do everything in plaintext so
with a little bit of work here's some
you know C code that you can kind of see
here basically I store it all on a
struct and I keep track of just the
number of seconds and then I just store
the ID and the actual data directly
there and so it's much smaller it's only
14 bytes as opposed to when I was using
about 40 before which is a big
difference when you're talking about
really fast systems so more or less how
I read it into the Wolfram language I've
got this nice little format that allows
me to ingest all that and just real
quick I'll run this real fast here this
one file which is about a 10-minute car
ride it still gives me about half a
million points so it's it's it's pretty
um it's pretty intense
as far as that and basically when I
first got started this is basically all
I had I had you know the time this is
the second so two seconds three seconds
and four seconds after start and then
these are the
and IDs and then basically the raw data
is just a bunch of numbers and that's
basically all I had I didn't really have
anything else to go on there's really no
manual to reverse engineering your car
so as you might imagine there's a lot of
experimentation and research and stuff
like that to go hunt down what it all
means but if you do find things it's it
actually produces some neat useful
information so for example here I
haven't shown the details how I get it
into a time series and that sort of
stuff but if you pull out a specific ID
on you pick out a specific bite you can
actually plot out something useful like
this is the the temperature I believe
it's the engine temperature the scale
factors of course are not right there
but anyways this manual stuff was kind
of painful to do to ingest the file poke
around at it and once I had gotten
basically the rough understanding I
needed a way to go faster so I found it
was easier to just build a GUI with
dynamic module which I'll show here I
learned a lot from Liu's talks highly
recommend seeing his stuff and of course
this isn't the most beautiful interface
in the world but it works pretty well so
I've been able to based on the file name
encode what day and minute things
started and then from there I just use
the counter of the seconds to be able to
keep track of stuff that way it keeps
everything small and simple and easy to
handle that way so we just choose a day
maybe we'll just choose PI day we can
select a different data plot here so
this is the start times column the end
times column and then all of this stuff
here is stuff that I've found in the
cars information so like if I look at
say the accelerator pedal for example
you can see there's a nice little
display for it I'm in addition to some
other stuff like how often each can idea
is sent as well so for example you know
that's the accelerator pedal probably
more interesting it's the speedometer
perhaps I mean kind of see where I
stopped and you know I get up to about
45 or so something like that and it's
kind of useful that way but of course
the thing I was most interested in was
grabbing the fuel flow which I can get
here and you may go wow how did you know
what the units were well after a lot of
research and poking around I found those
and it takes a little bit and there's a
lot of tools in
all that I had to make to be able to
combine bites together in the right way
and attach them you know the right
factors that I had to look up and find
and then you may go are those factors
correct and we'll we'll see that a
little bit here too that we can verify
that at least for sure this one is
correct as well ah but the idea here is
with this interface here is that you can
punch in IDs you can give them names you
can change the actual Wolfram language
code that's used here like for example I
have think I call it fuel economy um I
can use Wolfram language code here to
clip everything so that you know when
I'm coasting you know I don't get a
million miles to the gallon how am i
showing up so it makes things a little
easier to see on a plot this way in
there but anyways there's I can add
other options and stuff like that into
it's been pretty nice to be able to
customize it and poke through and
compare different trips and that sort of
stuff and load it dynamically and play
with various things as I go and hunt
down where the information has come from
and all that so anyways that's kind of
the idea there one last thing I'll point
out too is that it's also been nice to
look at the actual message space itself
where certain things live I know this
doesn't really look super great but I
also want it be big enough so you can
see it but I found temperatures all
individual wheel speeds all are on this
one ID here and that sort of thing so
there's there's a lot of cool stuff
there that I've been able to build using
this information I've been able to hunt
down with the interface which is kind of
nice yeah
right so this is sort of grouped by bite
so across here these bigger sections are
bite numbers so this is by twan by 2 by
3 people who are familiar with lower
level languages probably don't like that
I chose one but Wolfram language slot 0
is a different meaning so um but yeah
these are the bytes and the the bit
numbers are also there too sometimes
these things aren't always done in terms
of you know individual bytes I haven't
found anything that's been super useful
that doesn't line up with bytes yet but
I yeah yeah right yeah and so the wheels
for example all live the individual
speeds live on one row or for one
message so that's for like d4 for
example so a lot of these things are
sort of packed together so that they're
meaningful to various systems you do
around corners I mean maybe not
significantly but there's definitely a
difference um it's pretty interesting I
one time I it's too bad I wasn't
recording I was driving through some ice
and definitely spun the wheels a lot
it's an all-wheel drive vehicle so it's
not quite so impressive but it would
have been nice to see that information
and go back and go wow look what really
happened but haven't haven't driven
through some ice yet to really see that
yeah maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow from
what I hear the weather is pretty bad so
anyways that's kind of the tool I used
and was able to you know poke around at
various things that way and that was
kind of nice um in some sense because I
could zoom in on particular trips and if
I could remember all on this day on this
trip you know I did this or I did that
and I could kind of hunt things down but
if I want to do more than that like
plotting multiple things it's kind of
hard to do of course I guess I didn't
really show it here but some of the
niceties that I put in is like a copy
button so that I can you know paste it
and get out a time-series object and if
I do that for a couple days I could
manually you know put together um you
know a dateless plot that has them all
on there and that kind of stuff that
gets a little tricky and kind of manual
and around that time I was actually
looking into aligning to some GPS data I
really did not know how to really tie
that into the interface without you know
rewriting it signify
kentley so in order to avoid that I
started to think how am I going to do
this how I'm gonna keep track of this
how do I know how to group trips and
then it dawned on me one day I thought
well why not just make the trips
entities and build an entity store so I
did that that's really nice because now
I can actually filter my trips with
implicit entity class syntax and you
know since there's I've accumulated
about 20 gigabytes of data now it's not
so easy to just import it all that
doesn't really work for for very many of
them so instead I just only load the
core metadata from all these you know
based on the file name which has the
date stamp on it and then I can get you
know a reference to the file where all
the other information lives and from the
the can GUI interface that I had made
before I can actually extract other
information and make actual nice time
series objects with units um as we saw
in Eric's talk just before this based on
all that exploration I did and from
there entities it's really easy to add
more properties and that sort of stuff
to be able to align to things so I won't
run it here because it takes a minute
for it to run but this is basically the
code in right here where basically the
code just takes a directory where I have
all 20 gigabytes of data directory that
has the plot choices as I call them
that's all the stuff I found in the can
gooey stuff and then a date have been
where I've been dumping every ten
seconds of my GPS position when I'm
connected to the Bluetooth in my car
more on that later but again I've
registered it now I've got this nice
trip entity type loaded in and just so I
don't have to run this either since
it'll probably take a while to get the
GPS information but these are some of
the properties I have the date how long
it is you know start and end positions
even dates times the reference to the
file and that sort of thing and if I
have multiple trips in a day the trip
numbers also they're baked into the
canonical name and so this allows me to
do some nice things and plot things
together more nicely like the gas and
the brakes for example you can see that
the relationship there the scales are
kind of off there but you know you can
still kind of see it and so I got into a
little more and I won't really run this
too much basically I've got the ability
to pull out the fuel flow time series
and from there I wondered you know in
order to check if the if the scale
factors are actually right on the fuel
flow how can I verify that and one way
to do it is to actually just integrate
the fuel flow so I wrote a little piece
of code that I may eventually put on the
function or depository the more or less
integrates the the time series and so
when you do that for a single trip for
example you get a reasonable number out
like you know point eight point one
eight gallons which isn't so doesn't
seem so far off so I thought I would
check it and so I can and if you do map
this over the whole thing for a period
of time that I had been using before
with my low-tech web form I wound up
with about twelve gallons and I thought
well twelve gallons is actually not too
far off from the my tank size it's about
fourteen gallons so and I don't all the
way go to the bottom you know so I
checked it and if I compare to it it's
actually pretty close I get about twelve
point three gallons so it's a little
less than what I'm getting there but for
the most part that's pretty close so I
did it on a larger scale and you know
just with a simple scatter plot in a
perfect world this would you know they
were exactly aligned with each other
they would be a nice perfectly straight
line with a slope of one but it's it's
not quite there and you can see there's
some outliers sometimes I I can't have
it plugged in and so there's less fuel
being used according to what the Arduino
sees and what the receipt sees so to
speak so that's why there's some things
that are off sometimes it's the other
way on there's a couple outliers there
but I should probably use find anomalies
here to rip those out and check that the
slope is better but getting a slope of
about point eight nine is not too bad so
it agrees pretty well maybe I can change
that factor now um yep well see yeah it
definitely varies a lot there too but
again this is only interested in just
how much fuel I use so yeah there's
probably some variation there too that
needs to be taken into account I don't I
have not yet quite found out the the the
slope of the car I don't know if that's
reported on there but keeping my eye out
for it to see if that makes a difference
yeah yeah in champaign it would be very
flat that's true so there's some other
neat things I've been able to do is look
like at my fuel economy
over over the course of a year or well
grouping by month regardless of year and
that sort of thing I had originally
thought that my gas mileage would be
higher and you know summer months and
stuff like that but I guess my air
conditioner does more damage than I
realized to that and so it actually
increases quite a bit in you know
September and October it takes a big
nose dive in like November and December
when it gets cold and I have to let it
warm up longer and that sort of stuff
from there but anyways I won't spend a
lot of time on that going a little
further I'll talk a little more about
the GPS data that I've put in so
basically I had the idea boy it'd be
nice to know in order to plan this stuff
out if I knew where the car was I might
be able to know where the steering wheel
is or when I go fastest or maybe even
find some cooler things like how long I
spend at intersections and stuff like
that so I just installed a little app on
my phone
gravity even learned Android programming
from scratch since I I'm not as familiar
with that I didn't have a lot of time to
learn that even though I want to I
haven't had it I had a lot of time to do
it so I used an automation app called
macro droid but pretty much every
automation app out there is probably
able to do it without much effort and so
I just used the Bluetooth connection
whenever it triggers that I'm connected
to the car then it just every 10 seconds
just logs my location speed and accuracy
and the time that's associated with that
position as well and so as an example
trip I know this is a little small here
we'll get a zoomed in one but you can
see here this is wolfram so we're
probably like right over here now but
this is the wolfram parking lot and so
you can see I went over and I made a
turn and I stopped it a couple
stoplights here and that sort of thing
and work my way up towards a busy area
of town that way the red which is kind
of hard to see maybe if I just jump to
the next slide it's easier the red dots
are the accuracy so that's the accuracy
to which the position is they're the
center of it of course is the position
that's reported and the blue dots are
just there as a guide so you can kind of
see what they are but I have nice little
tooltips the kind of show of the time
the position and the speed as well which
I haven't really incorporated into this
particular plot but as you can see when
you look at the roads I'm the red is
actually much wider than Honda lanes
sometimes our
it's not really good enough to do like
Lane level expertise accuracy you know
and say oh I've spent more time in the
right lane in the left lane
so I basically I have to do you know if
I'm gonna know which direction I'm
facing I have to use context when was
the previous point and that kind of
stuff but it's good enough to get an
idea of where things are and kind of
where I've been so basically for a long
time I've been collecting these points
probably more substantially in the past
several months when I switched to
actually being able to do it once I'd
figured it out every so often but I've
basically got about seventy thousand
points in there so over the course of
almost a year in total most of my time
has been spent in Champaign because I
used to live here and then about half of
the time I moved to Fort Wayne and does
it family in Indianapolis so oh I guess
I should go show a little more of this
there's some gaps here when I was
playing experimenting with things it
looks like most of my trips are on the
weekend as opposed to during the week
and that's kind of nice time
distribution as well if you look at all
of the data where all I've been this is
kind of where it is to give you an idea
kind of where it is of course here we
are in Champaign that's where about half
the time we've spent about twenty
thousand points there almost twenty
thousand points in Fort Wayne as well
where I moved to and I've taken many
trips around it as a family and other
things and you can see that I went down
this way and apparently I I just don't
have any data around Terre Haute I guess
the either my phone died or the GPS
signals not super great there I'm not
sure but it is interesting to see that
another thing I looked into was when I'm
under 15 miles an hour where I'm
basically stopped and it's interesting
that you know the destination cities
that I've been to you know is where
you'd expect to see that but I also see
a lot of stuff with us if I can find my
cursor with interstates as well where
there's been construction and other
things like that on say 74 or 69 and
various roads there so it's kind of nice
to be able to see where these things
happened and we need to zoom in a little
further on those areas on interstates
and find out where exactly the
construction was and and other things
that way
of course if we zoom in even further it
gets a little more interesting so this
is map of Champaign I've sort of
anonymized the data a little bit and
tried to avoid obvious places where I
spend a ton of time like in the wolfram
parking lot for example where I would
you know it would be very blue there and
everything else would be basically flat
so I tried to remove some of those but
you can see definitely some
intersections are very bad with stuff
but definitely I've been kind of in all
over over the course of you know almost
a year in Champaign another neat thing
too is if you look at just the times
when I'm less than 15 miles an hour you
can really see my commute coming into
play where that one intersection is
really bad I think there's a stop sign
here's you know an intersection here you
know where I spend a lot of time that
way
to go a little further though it's a
little different in Fort Wayne it's not
on the nice grid things are a little
more you know moved around so hexagons
make a little more sense here but
definitely there's a lot of traffic
areas as you go deeper into the center
of town and stuff like that the stopped
areas this intersection is pretty bad I
think there's a grocery store up here
which is probably why that one's so so
intense there but it is kind of neat to
look at and see where I've been and you
know how it goes
Indianapolis similar story there it's
not quite as clear and everything but in
the last little bit I did a little fun
thing where I found out where I parked
in the wolfram parking lot and I only
have about 118 points there so it's not
like super great but it's kind of more
of a fun thing to kind of look at so for
reference we are in here so caddy
corners across the street is where the
parking lot is and so all the little
dots there kind of show where I have
parked if we zoom in a little closer to
kind of see what's going on if you
change the grid size to be around the
size of a parking spot you can kind of
see where I've parked where I choose to
park obviously I don't leave my car in
the aisle or anything like that so it
probably should be skewed a little bit
more towards this side I don't think I
ever parked in the grass I'm pretty
confident I didn't park over here and
I'm pretty confident I didn't park at
yeah at the darlings either and be
tempted to get the frozen custard there
but it is a nice use to be able to kind
of see things that way so more of a fun
gimmicky thing than anything
else that way but so yeah so that kind
of wraps things up there on what I've
done some things I do want to do I'd
like to be able to detect who's driving
there's a couple of ways to do that one
is if I have whoever else is driving
install the same automation app on their
phone then I can just have the data bin
with an extra field in it to be able to
tell where you know who it is and that
sort of stuff it'd also be nice if I
could hook up a Wi-Fi chip to it so that
I could keep hotspot on my phone and
then you know every couple seconds or
something upload to the cloud and dump
things into a day - been there with you
know a smaller set of data not the whole
thing I wouldn't be able to squeeze in
everything to it but you know some of
the things I'm more interested in speed
gas mileage that kind of stuff I'd also
like to get into you know live-streaming
the data onto a screen so that I can
interactively you know do things rather
than like how I found the doors where I
had to just remember which doors I
opened and closed and then open and
close them and shut them like five or
ten times and a particular order so that
I could go back through the data and
hunt it down some other things I want to
do is like dead reckoning and odometry
and some path analysis stuff it's it's
kind of messy there but I'm working on
it and aligning the GPS data is really
helpful there to be able to piece that
kind of stuff together so and I guess I
guess I'm out of time here but that's
more or less it so thanks
you